first of all congratulations uh movie's
a huge success and you are hilarious in
this movie so you should be very happy
uh yeah you really deserve
all good things and
i didn't realize uh because
andy and i and the band we're all new to
this warner brothers lot which we love
but i don't know everything that shoots
here and apparently you you shoot on the
slide but i don't think we've seen each
other yet
i have seen you you've seen me
and i think i scared you weird you
we shoot on stage 24. i don't even know
where that is but
i have watched you forever
and then
i i'm never outside we're always like in
the stage and working and i happened to
be outside and you were just because
you're very tall you had quite a clip
going yeah when you were i've walked
very quickly yeah it's impressive yeah
it's impressive if you could see him
walk um and you were walking past and i
was like oh my god he's it like i was
like say something cool like say
something funny it all depends on your
next statement and the only thing i
thought to do was i looked at you and
went
and it was
it was not i really did i was like i
don't
i did you did this
i thought i guess to give you a lot of
pelvis or something yeah yeah it was
really awkward and you just went
you would all it's what all the ladies
do to me when they see me
next time please say hi yeah uh now uh
bridesmaids i would think you know
it's such a cliche in this business
people say oh you made this movie you
guys what a great cast you must have had
a lot of fun this is one of those movies
where you look at the cast you think you
must have had a good time together
because it's such
you're such funny women hanging out
together did you get to uh like hang out
off the set or was it just hanging out
did you go anywhere did you party did
you do anything crazy
we did some research for the film
because we're serious actors okay so
as
you know if you're doing a play or
anything he knows he's a real actor um
originally i think she was talking to me
[Applause]
we originally in the in the script we
were supposed to the bachelorette party
was going to be at a strip club so
trying to be very um
correct we went to hollywood men which
is a strip club here in la anyone no one
no one hollywood men oh all right which
i go to thunder down under oh
nice so
so you went to a strip club with the
other actresses we went kristen got a
party bus
there may have been adult beverages
involved i'm not sure i don't remember
and uh
then there were yeah
and we went and just saw a lot of
incredibly
greased up men with like long curly
moosed hair
and it was just a lot of like
peek-a-booing it was like somebody would
come out i'm sorry to peek-a-boo
it was like a lot of
there was like a matrix scene
and then they got their ass so they
don't just come out and dance they act
out scenes from movies it's a full
fantastic show
and they came out in like full-length
leather dusters because they were doing
the matrix yeah and that one part where
he goes like
neo would go backwards yeah they did
that part but he had a big rope around
his waist so when he leaned back he
didn't fall
so so instead of being this like cool
like dance move somebody off stage is
just like holding the rope and we were
like that's so sad yeah and then then
out of nowhere it would be like a fight
scene and then like a weird like kind of
just show like a little cheek yeah
was that something that was i mean
is that erotic is that is that
it was i think when guys go to a strip
club it's like she's really into me yeah
she likes me and we were all like once
the p like once they started taking
their clothes off we were like no
just a lot of like it was kind of like
my movie i knew who were you to talk you
were yeah maybe that's where i learned
it um you're you're i want to talk about
your character your character in the
film is is so funny and
and it does feel like i've
i think a lot of us think we've met this
woman before
well there's some i mean i love those
midwestern women and
i mean really when i first read it the
first person i thought it was guy fieri
from the food network
that was my first that's like i wanted
to that's why i like the shirt and the
candle right and i kept trying to wear
glass like every scene i would have like
my glasses on the back of my head and i
tried for a long time to convince them
to let me wear like short white spiky
hair they're like you can't actually be
a guy fiance like it's gotta be like
like cut it off at some point
but
so uh so that was what you were going
for and
it's it's also there's sort of a
in some scenes it seems like you're
almost playing like this neutral gender
thing you know what is that you know
what i'm talking about oh i don't i i
think she's about as girly as is like
i can make her i mean i'm in an athletic
sandal and a
unflattering doctor but
[Laughter]
i just had a baby and just for everyone
don't wear dockers no offense to dockers
but not right after you've had a child
it i just got shorter and round i look
like a weeble in that movie it was like
all five of the women are like they're
in like a 12 inch heel and they're all
like bronzed and beautiful and roseburn
is somehow lit from within and everybody
looks amazing and i felt like all the
crew guys were like those five women are
hot and who's the little short guy
like i just i look like a man for sure i
think i could i think that some of the
crew guys were like what's happening
well we have a clip here from the movie
anything we need to know for this
that fella that i believe i'm accosting
if it's the clip i think it is uh
is my actual husband yeah cone yeah
which some of our friends find it
disturbing
it's really funny though let's take a
look at this clip from bridesmaids
i gotta know where you keep the gun man
i mean is it ankle hip lower back you
don't
between the cheeks do you no i don't
stick a gun
at my butt i mean that's that's
i just knew of a guy
that got did a lot of undercover work
and all i know is he had tape marks all
up and down his cheeks
that can't be true people don't keep
guns up their asses because if you
needed to use it are you gonna get it he
cut a hole in his pocket what he was he
was in his back pocket you've got to get
something out of your ass and you cut a
hole in the back of your jeans you want
to tell me you can't get to something
i don't have a gun for you to put up my
ass to make it my nano i will show you i
will you get any scissors i will cut a
hole in my pocket
and i you'll never find this again until
i want you to find it
mike and molly airs mondays at 9 30 on
cbs bridesmaids is in theaters now
melissa really a joy to talk to you
thanks so much congratulations
listen mccarthy we'll be right back